[Music]
hey river babes are you ready for some
musical mayhem because we are finally
back I'm your host Liane angular and
this is your Sweetwater secrets preview
show for episode 218 chapter 31 a night
to remember
aka it's the musical episode now in
addition to reading your hisses and
kisses comments from the last episode
which feels like forever ago this week's
preview is packed with exclusive
interviews with Camilla Mendez Ashley
Marie and Madeline Pech why because I
love you and because I feel like it's
been too long since our last episode and
I'm good with but now let's take a look
at some of your comments about episode
217 chapter 30 the noose tightens
because truthfully after all these
breaks have completely forgotten where
we left off you have hurt me today
kicking things off mari Johnston posted
kisses to Jughead and the serpent's
kicking down the door to save the
Cooper's I so loved that scene I
replayed it at least a hundred times and
River ray wrote kisses Tanana Rose for
being an OG Shoni shipper I second that
and at this point Nana roses Bay and we
must protect her at all costs now adding
to that a meal a said that she loved
Madelyn patches behind the scenes Shoni
story because she wrote that snot tastic
kiss was my favorite riverdale scene
ever can't argue with you there and lily
Murray wrote hisses to Josie for leaving
the Cheryl hunt now I hear you Lilly I
can see why fans would be a little
bummed that Josie noped out of the save
Cheryl mission but here's what Josie
herself Ashley Marie had to tell me
about Josie and Cheryl's future
friendship
Josie now knows that Cheryl had a crush
on her and I think a lot of people
forgot Cheryl gave her a pig's heart yes
she did and she rightfully got a little
upset about that are we gonna see those
two girls address this in the episodes
moving forward yes yes you absolutely
will
it was it like for you to get those
answers because that's true lion
happened and it was buried under a lot
of other things and I think fans almost
forgot like oh yeah you know it was nice
to see what happened for me as an actor
it's just like oh man she was running
away she's not gonna help but I get why
she would be conflicted with it and I am
happy to see what the end result is
after you know they figured things out
and I can tell you that you will get to
see that in the musical episode now
moving on to a really interesting theory
Cookie Monster which great handle name
posted I know this makes me sound like a
total nerd but I can't help to comment
on this connection in Shakespeare's
Hamlet Claudius was the name of Hamlet's
uncle who immediately married Hamlet's
mom after he killed her husband slash
his brother coincidence I think not very
interesting connection meanwhile
Brittany Hanks is asking everyone is
everyone forgetting that agent Adams
might be the black hood oh my god of
course I just think the agent Adams was
wearing a black hood during that scene I
don't think he's actually the black hood
I just think there are way too many
people in Riverdale with the exact same
black ski mask and they clearly all need
to start shopping somewhere else big
mistake big huge and there was lots of
love for a new Riverdale duo Riverdale
theories posted kisses to Veronica and
Tony's new friendship and a lot of you
loved Veronica and Tony's sultry Sheryl
saving cat suits now take a look at what
Camilla Mendes told me about her fierce
on song girl we've got to talk about
your spy outfit I know Roberto
specifically asked that I was dressed in
a black cat suit I think he has his own
like fangirls dreams and now not a cat
suit that I've seen before you look
sensational like when you're running
down those hallways I was like oh girl
be careful I felt like a superhero but I
had the psy high boots they're thick
heels but it was it was a long day of
running and heels
Vanessa looked amazing Thank You sexiest
superheroes ever and wrapping up our fan
comments page go throat hisses - the
three week break all these breaks
we were on a break now we weren't why
don't happen to you to affiliate page
I feel like Riverdale has been losing a
lot of momentum with all these breaks
and it's been really hard to stay
excited about all the twists and turns
is that why you guys are pissed but the
good news is that we have five episodes
left and no more breaks whoa
all right ready for some more good news
the musical episode is finally here and
I've already seen this toe-tapping
episode mmm three times and I can
promise you it's truly going to be a
night that you'll never forget but don't
just take my word for it
here's what the lovely Madeline Pech had
to tell me about what fans can expect
from this one-of-a-kind
musical event the musical episode is
coming up please talk to me about you
embodying the role of Miss Carrie
first of all Harry is one of my favorite
movies so when he told me we were doing
this I was like dying I'm happiness many
call me he's like so you're gonna be
Carrie White and I was like I was so
excited it turned out so much I mean we
all knew was gonna be amazing even
better than we thought it would and it
was like the funnest episode to shoo and
watching it my favorite episode to watch
and I think as a viewer they're gonna
feel that way too because it kind of
takes you out of this like grim
Riverdale where we've been and puts you
in like a new exciting place for a
little bit and brings you back to the
Grimm again it's so cool and look at
this cute little play bill that CW sent
me for Carrie the musical now do you
guys want more Madeline patch yeah me
too
so I have a special surprise for you all
now in lieu of my three clues about this
week's episode Matt will be joining me
on Wednesday morning for a live episode
of Sweetwater secrets and she'll be
taking your questions gasp that's right
you're getting three episodes of
Sweetwater this week you're getting the
preview that you're watching right now a
live episode with Madeline Pech and your
after show episode that will be packed
with exclusive scoop from Camilla Mendez
KJ Appa and more talking all about the
episodes biggest moment a lot of time to
be alive so keep it locked to my Twitter
page for all the details on when
Madeline will be joining the show and
then hit the comments right now and send
me your questions for Mads in the
meantime please give this video a like
and I will see you soon with the babes
kisses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]